[Music]
it was very important to me to shoot
this on film
i believe in it tremendously it still
has a quality
that nothing else can duplicate i
actually got the opportunity to shoot
on imax which was mind-blowing the
footage that you get back from it
is stunning it's like nothing else if
you get to see this film projected
in film on a full-size imac screen
you'll never forget it
we really wanted the film to have a
sense of spectacle
and imax is just one of the most
incredibly immersive mediums in the film
arena
petty's vision for this movie is so
ambitious
the stories are personal and beautiful
and
intimate but at the same time they're
huge and big and mind-blowing
there's a quality to immulsive print
filmmaking it's like the highest level
of a oil paint
quality for an artist the movie is
already so
visceral and vivid and beautifully shot
and seeing it
on imax is just going to take it to the
next level
it just looks gorgeous and everybody
looks beautiful
the world is so big and the quality is
so high
it's just a great experience
you